you know Nina coming back to memoria you
know that the IndieGoGo campaign was
just launched recently but our
understanding is you know the
development of this story actually goes
back quite a bit can you can you just
explain there can you just take a sign
that during like how long have you been
working on you know the Palo Alto
stories in this you know the short film
and now the feature films uh I think
it's been almost two years now when
James asked me to write the short films
um I did and he liked them so then he
asked me to write a feature which I
started doing so like there was like a
good six month period when I was writing
the first draft of the feature and then
Vlad came on board and then we tweaked
the first draft of the script and we
started working on it together so it's
been about two years I mean initially
this project was we wanted it to happen
like either earlier this year or late
last year but James schedules so hectic
and we wanted to make sure that the
project was like as good as it could
possibly be and it is it is it really
gonna happen I mean can you believe it's
really gonna happen I'd better happen oh
I think is gonna happen I mean our
producer iris who's like the best
producer ever she she's like making sure
that the timing and we were contacting
like some people and some companies and
um like we're auditioning people so it
better happen I'm really on the side of
her down now have you actually been to
Palo Alto have you know that's the
weirdest part is like so when I wrote
the first draft of the script before
blab came on board I like I took James
of stories and I sort of made them my
own like I made the characters like sort
of like more gritty and because it's
based on like me also growing up in
South Detroit as well as like James the
story so it's got like myself in it and
then you know James read the script for
the first time months ago and he's like
this is great this is great but uh you
should go to palo alto because i don't
think you know I don't know it is like
the kids in our story they're like
skateboarders and they go to shows and
like but apparently Palo Alto is like
there was like a very just a very small
clique of that and the rest is like
Silicon Valley kids but we'll make it
work yeah that actually I'm doing a
little self disclosure they're actually
one of the first guys I had a crush on
was a skater guy that was from Palo Alto
because that's where I grew up so there
was a very few of those and that's one
of the reasons I liked him but then he
kind of got sucked into the popular
crowd so I he just wasn't that that's
good that's good then we gotta see her
okay i knows what I know that that's
real